- Dans le passé, des périodes
de grande inflation ont
déstabilisé les économies.
Comme dans les années 70, où
deux période de choc pétrolier
ont fait exploser non seulement
les prix du carburant...
- Qu'est-ce qui a
le plus augmenté?
- Moi, je dirais
que c'est le steak.
- ... mais aussi
les prix en général.
- Savez-vous que le prix du lait
a augmenté ce matin encore?
- Encore?
- C'est effrayant,
on ne pourra plus vivre.
- Aussi bien de s'acheter
une bouteille de bière et ça va
être bien mieux, câline!
- L'inflation est galopante
pendant plus de 10 ans.
Et il y a une anomalie. Bien que
les prix ne cessent d'augmenter,
la croissance, elle, est
au ralenti. On appelle ça
la stagflation. Et la solution
va venir des États-Unis au début
des années 80 avec la hausse
des taux d'intérêt.
NICOLAS VINCENT, prof. titulaire
d'économie, HEC Montréal
- Évidemment, ça, ça a aussi
un effet secondaire. Et l'effet
secondaire, c'est quoi? Bien,
c'est de créer une récession.
Donc, une hausse des chômages,
perte d'emploi et c'est ça, donc
des difficultés économiques.
- Aujourd'hui, on est bien loin
de connaître une inflation
semblable à celle des années 70.
Mais on connaît aussi
une situation inusitée
avec la COVID. Bien qu'on
se relève à peine d'une crise,
les gens ont de l'épargne
et peuvent dépenser.
- Et ça, c'est complètement
atypique. On n'aurait jamais vu
ça dans une récession
précédente. Et la raison pour
ça, bien, ce sont les programmes
d'aide qui ont été mis
en place. Donc, on se retrouve
maintenant au moment une reprise
avec des gens qui ont beaucoup
de liquidités. Et, je dirais,
la crainte principale des
économistes, pour une inflation
à plus long terme, ce serait que
ces liquidités, comment dire,
soient libérées très rapidement
et que les gens se mettent
à consommer très rapidement sans
que l'offre ne puisse suivre.
- Plusieurs économistes estiment
que l'actuelle inflation
est seulement transitoire,
qu'elle est le signal normal
d'une reprise après les premiers
mois de la pandémie
où les prix ont même baissé.
- Si on regarde où était le
niveau des prix en février 2020
par rapport au niveau des prix
en juillet 2021, il y a eu
effectivement une augmentation
des prix à un taux de presque
exactement 2 %. C'était
du rattrapage. Mais maintenant,
donc, la grande question,
c'est : est-ce que ça va
persister encore longtemps?
- L'effet de spirale n'est pas
impossible, notamment si les
travailleurs demandent à être
compensés pour l'inflation.
- On n'a pas d'équivalent
historique sur lesquels se baser
pour dire : voici ce qui va
se produire. Donc, il n'y a pas
encore une énorme inquiétude,
mais c'est sûr que c'est
un indicateur qui... qui
nous préoccupe et sur lequel
on garde un oeil ouvert.
- Et pour compliquer le tout,
si la Banque du Canada décidait
d'augmenter son taux directeur
pour freiner l'inflation,
les taux hypothécaires
augmenteraient eux aussi,
dans un contexte où la dette
hypothécaire des Canadiens
n'a jamais été aussi élevé